no man's sky coming to game pass
evidence of that next black ops game
and is the last of us part two really
coming out
i'm current devina and this is safe
state the big fun
time news show here on gamespot for
wednesday
june 10th we now have the official
launch trailer for the last of us part
two
but it doesn't show any new footage if
anything
it serves one purpose and that's to
remind you that's coming out
next friday which is nice because it was
announced years ago
and then it was given a release date and
then it was delayed and then
unfortunately it was delayed again
but it is coming out next friday
definitely for real but what is new is
that the game's esrb
rating has been released and you might
be
really surprised by what's on it
including violence
drugs sex gore
and blood didn't see any of that coming
you can read the full esrb rating on
gamespot.com
but be warned it technically has
spoilers so
tread carefully unless you don't care
otherwise
go for it there's more evidence that the
next call of duty game is gonna be
another black ops installment pro call
of duty player chance said on reddit
that he visited treyarch studios to
consult on the game's competitive
philosophy
now jr developed a black ops series so
if chance did go to treyarch to consult
them then that further eludes the next
one is going to be
a black ops installment there's also the
ps5 event that's happening tomorrow on
june 11th and there is a whole bunch of
speculation that we'll likely see
the next call of duty revealed during it
also in call of duty news
modern warfare season 4 which was
delayed got a new date and it's
tonight at 11 pm pacific happy birthday
coming to the game pass family is no
man's sky
and with a cross play it'll launch
alongside a new crossplay update
allowing xbox folk
pc folk and ps4 folk to play together
making it more like
everybody sky unless that's what no
man's
sky means because if it's no man's
sky then it belongs to everyone
and alongside no man's sky a whole bunch
of other games are coming to game pass
so many that i'm not going to list them
off and
i'm instilling trust that our editor
evan langer
will show an image showing all those
games so there they are you should
you should be seeing them now i trust
you evan
did you know play for all is happening
well it is it's a multi-week event
that's meant to raise money for both
black lives matter
and people fighting on the front line
for covin 19. and
alongside that we have a bunch of
exclusive content so so far we've done
interviews with people like the
co-creator of disintegration
we've also done interviews with people
from hearthstone and then for the
charity streams which happen every
single day from 12
p.m to 2 p.m we have special guests like
daniel dwyer who's going to be on
this friday for a full schedule of
everything to come
a link will be in the description below
alright that's it for today's news
unless something breaks in the time of
which this is being filmed and if that
happens then just stay tuned to gamespot
to see what it is
i'm current davina thanks for joining me
for today's safe state
see you later until next time
[Music]
bye
you